moving on to other news now and video
has been released of what's believed to
be a Ukrainian drone hitting a warship
in Russia's Black Sea port of novoto
Sisk cave hasn't claimed responsibility
for the strike but Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski has said that attacks
on Russian territory are inevitable
another video shows uh shows a damaged
ship being towed
Julia shapovalova is joining us live
from Moscow with more on this so what a
Russian official saying about the attack
you dear
yes the Russian Ministry of Defense has
issued a statement which reads that the
Armed Forces of Ukraine made an attempts
to attack Russia's Norris's Naval base
and the Black Sea with two unmanned both
of them were destroyed by fire coming
from Russian ships guarding the Bays
there so the video shows the Russian
Landing ship olenigorski gornyak tilted
a bit and then it was towed to the
repair docks where it was promised to be
repaired as soon as possible and after
the incident the port of norse's first
imposed a ban on the movement of All
Ships there but later they lifted it
that's according to the Caspian pipeline
Consortium Kim as you said did not
officially claim responsibility for that
tag but their reports on Ukrainian
social media describing how the
Ukrainian surface drone stuffed with 450
kilograms of explosives has attacked the
Russian ship with about 100 crew members
on board so talking about the Russian
officials no one draws any conclusions
at the moment so we're waiting for more
official reaction from them all right
Julia and there are also reports of a
second attack in Crimea what can you
tell us about that
yes indeed it's a separate incident of
course and we know that residents of
Crimea have it's a separate incident of
Crimea have published a video of uavs
hitting the Theodosia oil Depot in the
east of the peninsula Russia considers
Crimea its very own territory so the
Russian defense Ministry also made a
statement blaming kiev for that tag
according to the Russian military the
Ukrainian side carried out a terrorist
attack by aircraft type drones all of
them all their attacks were repelled so
according to the defense Ministry about
10 uavs were destroyed by Air Defense
Forces and three more drones were jammed
by electronic warfare equipment no
casualties or damage were reported there
Russian sources say their attacks on
fear dossier not accidental because
there are large oil reservoirs and a
power plants that connect the power
lines of Crimea plus both attacks on
Crimea and the black seat Fleet ship in
the viruses took place exactly after
reconnaissance by NATO Aviation and
satellite that's according to well I
mean that information is not official
that's according to telegram channel so
seems like Ukraine is expanding the area
with attacks and the conflict is
expanding to all right Yulia thank you
very much for that Julia shape of Oliver
with the latest on what we know so far
about both of those attacks from Moscow